Go to the planet Tython there you will
find the ancient ruins of a temple that
has a strong connection to the force
if he reaches out through the force
there's a chance a jedi may sense his
presence and come searching for him.
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this is going
to be my mandalorian season 2 video for the jedi
that ahsoka teased at the end of the episode as
well as the jedi temple at tython that she was
talking about if you're new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos we'll
do a giveaway for disney plus memberships all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber and leave
all your theories on the video which jedi or sith
or dark side force users will show up to answer
grogu's call careful for spoilers for everything
that's happened on the mandalorians so far if
you haven't seen any of the episodes i'll number
these as we go along to stay organized starting at
the end of season 2 episode 5 ahsoka tano tells
mando that she can't train grogu because of the
father-son attachment that he's formed also even
though she doesn't say anything to him about grand
admiral thrawn is implied tracking him down is her
real priority now which dave filoni also talked a
little bit about in an interview right after the
episode i'll explain what he said in a second
because it has a lot to do with the future
of the live-action rosario dawson version of
ahsoka tano in these new star wars disney plus
series with the mandalorian and the potential
spin-off series that they're developing but she
does tell him to take grogu to the ruins of an
ancient jedi temple on tython and place him on top
of the seeing stone at the peak of the mountain
and there if grioku chooses to reach out through
the force the temple itself acts kind of like a
focusing array for the force it'll amplify his
signal to the rest of the galaxy in any jedi
or force users or force sensitives of any kind
good or bad will be able to hear him and pinpoint
his location so number nine the jedi temple that
ahsoka is talking about is actually from the old
republic game in knights of the old republic and
the darth bane novels and when she says ancient
that's an understatement tython is actually
supposed to be the birthplace of the jedi order
yes i know luke skywalker was supposed to be
hiding out at the original jedi temple on och 2
but as confusing as it sounds the temple of tython
actually predates the temple at og 2 because when
we say it's the birthplace of the jedi order
is actually the birthplace of the order that
predates what we would think of as the jedi order
when you talk about the jedi order you're mostly
talking about the ones that is depicted in the
movies the one that yoda luke skywalker anakin
skywalker obi-wan kenobi all belong to the one
that lasted for a thousand generations is the
guardians of peace around the galaxy the order
that came before that was actually called the jedi
which is actually two eyes slightly different
pronunciation slightly different spelling
so we're talking about an order that existed
more than 25 000 years ago the difference between
the jedi and the jedi is that the jedi actually
believed in three different schools of the force
the ashla which was referred to as the light side
of the force the bogan which represented the dark
side of the force and the bendu which represented
the balance between them like the bendu from star
wars rebels voiced by tom baker when he showed up
on that series that was dave filoni bringing that
stuff back into the canon the bendu itself is
actually super powerful and practice both dark
side and light side techniques making him much
more powerful than a traditional jedi number eight
eventually there was a schism between those who
believed that they should exclusively follow the
light side of the force and those who wanted to
only follow the dark side of the force and after
the light side won out they left tython to create
what you would consider the modern jedi order that
yoda that luke skywalker everyone else belonged
to in the movies in all the dark side force users
left and eventually found the sith race who were
already strong dark side practitioners dominated
them creating the ancient sith empire the rule of
two didn't actually become a thing much later till
darth bane came along so that's why luke skywalker
is still at the original jedi temple but tython
where mando is taking grogu is the original temple
used by the order that predated the jedi and the
sith it's just another really cool example of dave
filoni and john favreau plucking something out of
legends and making it candid again although
technically it kind of did show up during
the darth vader comics in the dr aphra comic but
they were only there briefly number seven there
are many light side jedi that we know survived
order 66 and newer ones who are canon that have
been introduced since revenge of the sith came out
but the ones i'm going to talk about during this
video are mostly just the ones who are still alive
right now after the events of return of the jedi
when the mandalorian is taking place because a
lot of jedi survived order 66 but then were later
hunted down by darth vader and the inquisitors and
killed before a new hope then you also have people
like yoda and obi-wan kenobi who have died but
do reappear often as force ghosts the jedi that
ahsoka tano was teasing might show up is going
to be somebody who will be alive and actually
able to train grogu just first off the bat yes of
course there's cal questus from jedi fallen order
the events of that game take place about five
years after revenge of the sith about 33 years ago
so cal kestis would have to be in his late 40s or
early 50s during the events of the mandalorian so
it would be kind of hard for cameron monahan to do
the katy sackoff boca tan thing and play both the
animated and live-action versions of the character
number six sara younda is also from the fallen
order game she's still alive at the end of that
so even though she'd be much much older she could
wind up appearing she'd be somewhere into her
late 60s a little older than luke skywalker
was during the last jedi so not that old but much
much older than ahsoka tano and i think a lot of
the characters that they're trying to populate in
the live-action series now on the mandalorian are
supposed to be younger so that they could continue
on in other live-action series or come back in the
mandalorian in future seasons but on the other
side of this equation talking about dark side or
other neutral force users that could show up
you have characters like the night sisters
and in fact there was actually a big nice
sister's dathomir easter egg during episode
5 without us even realizing it some of you
may have seen this after the episode came out
after the episode was released the star wars
people revealed in the show notes that morgan
ellsbeth the magistrate was actually from dathomir
remember the whole reason she served grand admiral
thrawn in the empire plundering worlds was because
her home planet was ravaged during the clone wars
while her home planet was dathomir meaning
she was born as a member of the night sisters
which explains a lot about her fighting abilities
in her knowledge of the jedi if you don't remember
what happened to dathomir and the night sisters
at the end of the clone wars count dooku in
emperor palpatine sent general grievous there to
destroy the night sisters back right at the end
of the clone wars but some of them survived they
also continued that story during the jedi fallen
order game with one of the surviving night sisters
trying to team up with calcus and you also fight a
former jedi master who's fallen to the dark side
and gone to dathomir to lead the knight brothers
if you don't follow a lot of the expanded material
you didn't watch the clone wars or star wars
rebels that's also where darth maul comes from
he is a quote-unquote son of dathomir the number
four of course we have to mention mace windu
samuel l jackson even wants to come back himself
this is that clip of him from celebration 2017
pitching his return to the star wars universe
while you're all sitting there i know you're all
in my corner on this we know jedis can fall from
incredible heights and survive so apparently i
am not dead miss windu is awaiting his return
let's make it happen fans have been theorizing
about mace windu what happened to him this whole
time where he has been people have wondered if
he's somehow related to finn because he's force
sensitive so there's just so many things that you
could do with that character after revenge of the
sith but then number three yes there's the obvious
choice of luke skywalker it's questionable what
dave filoni and john favreau have planned around
the bigger original trilogy characters during
this part of the timeline i've already done a
video explaining what luke skywalker is doing
right now right after the events of return of the
jedi he's quite literally flying around the galaxy
looking for force sensitive people to train so
that he can create a new jedi academy it seems
like a no-brainer opportunity to have him cameo
and just cast sebastian stan as a young version of
luke he actually even did a version of an audition
a while ago just as a joke mark hamill himself has
even kind of endorsed this because he's like you
definitely look like a younger version of me but
here's the thing with luke skywalker right now i
feel like he's kind of off limits like even ahsoka
tano has canonically never met luke skywalker
even though he did eventually learn about her
learning that his father had a padawan but it
wasn't till much later in his life and he didn't
actually wind up creating that jedi academy that
they featured during the last jedi till several
years after the events of the mandalorian series
right now luke is still in his late 20s and hasn't
found any of the padawans that wound up attending
that academy so number two as you probably guessed
by now it's most likely that at least one of the
jedi who ahsoka tano is referring to will wind up
being adult ezra bridger after he's come back
from the unknown regions with grand admiral thrawn
dave filoni was talking about this a little during
his recent interview he actually clarified some of
the timeline for these characters so in the rebels
finale he and thrawn go into the unknown regions
at the end of the episode right before a new hope
then there's an epilogue which is sort of like
a post-credit scene at the very end they jump
forward in the timeline several years after the
events of return of the jedi where a much older
version of ahsoka tano comes to get sabine wren so
they can go find ezra bridger originally everyone
thought that that was happening right after the
battle of endor but now in this new interview dave
filoni is implying that the scene might actually
happen after the events of the mandalorian series
that makes things a little more confusing for
where these characters show up during the timeline
but i think the reason that he said it that way is
because they're going to cover that story ahsoka
going to take down thrawn and finding ezra with
sabine on the rumored live-action ahsoka spin-off
series with rosario dawson but everything that's
happening on the mandalorian is after thrawn has
made it back from the unknown regions and if he's
made it back that also means that ezra probably
made it back too so number one no idea which
actor they would get to play him obviously this
is rahul kohli who's been posting all this fan art
no idea if we'd see him during mandalorian season
2 or season 3 i think it might be season 3 before
they fully pay off the grogu jedi beacon twist
but also once a jedi does show up that probably
won't be the end of it because if you set off
an alarm that big in the force not everybody is
going to hear it around the galaxy at the exact
same time so in later episodes later seasons
we might see other dark side light side force
users showing up because they heard this call
early on during season 2. there's a ton of new
characters or super deep cuts from the non-canon
legends stuff and video games that they can
totally pull in future seasons any character you
could possibly think of everything is fair game
to show up but let me know in the comments which
jedi or dark side force users do you think will
show up to answer grogu's call and when do you
think that we'll see live action ezra bridger
for the first time and sabine for that matter
a lot of these characters go hand in hand so if
one shows up the others will also probably show
up as well i'll do more bonus videos this week
but my full mandalorian season 2 episode 6 video
will post friday just like normal everyone click
here for my full mandalorian season 2 episode 5
ahsoka tano video and click here for my new
ahsoka tano vs grand admiral thrawn teaser video
thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe this is the way!